a non-profit held an event at a Nevada
women's prison today and one of the
first visits to a state prison actually
since covered restrictions were lifted
as Joshua peguero reports the group aims
to make sure when inmates are released
they don't come back since it's founding
in 1976 it is the first time prison
fellowship has visited a facility in
Nevada
the women heard from volunteers of
prison fellowship Ashley page was one of
them she talked about her mother who
spent years in the Florida prison system
we've all fallen short and we've all
made mistakes but we are not who that is
we are not the mistakes that we make
prison fellowship offers an academy to
Those Behind Bars Regional director of
Pamela Gonzalez says they teach students
the skills to build healthy
relationships and lead a positive life
using Christianity everybody deserves a
second chance uh
[Music]
it to go home different the change for
students starts behind the Prison Walls
we come in with programming and help
them unlearn some of those behaviors and
think in more a positive manner Lawrence
McClure Correctional Center in Las Vegas
is the only women's facility in the
state Brian Williams is the deputy
director of programs at the Department
of Corrections he says doc looks to
partner with non-profits like prison
fellowship to put forth resources they
can't afford the more busy they are the
more occupied they are when they're
participating in something that's
positive
it helps get rid of some of those
negative barriers that they normally
would participate in there isn't
Fellowship stresses that the General
Public second chance to those who were
previously or currently incarcerated
reporting at the Florence McClure
Women's Correctional Center Joshua 8
News Now